police forensic officers worked
throughout the night at the crime scene
where the killing took place much of
this area is still sealed off and maybe
for some time yet a private ambulance
arrived in the middle of the night and
was taken through the police cordon it
all started on this street in Woollett
in the middle of the afternoon this car
was driven onto the pavement and into
the path of a man believed to be a
serving soldier two men got out of the
car and carried out a savage attack new
images of the moments after this
incident are emerging all the time
this was Scout leader Ingrid Lu while
Kennett confronting one of the alleged
attackers the mother of two stood just a
few feet away he had would appear to be
a knife in his left hand speaking to The
Daily Telegraph she said the man told
her we want to start a war in London and
this haunting still image taken from a
video shot by an eyewitness on a camera
phone shows the other suspect
brandishing what looks like a meat
cleaver he spoke at length to the camera
before walking off
eyewitnesses recalled what they saw in
horrific detail animal I'm just standing
there watching this guy roam around the
body would be some a friend doing the
other side and as the police pulled up
they both looked at the police car and
then the one with the gun walked towards
the police car sometimes she saw him
London's most senior police officer said
the investigation was now being led by
the counterterrorism command we've seen
a horrific attack on the streets of
London a terrible murder has been as
occurred we've launched an investigation
led by the counter-terrorist command and
we've made two arrests in relation to
that awful crime we now ask that people
obviously give us the opportunity to
thoroughly investigate this crime to
make sure we get to the bottom of who
committed it and
I purchased that people remain calm
during that process but it was anything
but calm on the streets of Woollett at
night anger returned the English Defence
League staged a small demonstration
which at times ended in clashes with
police we have leaders leaders tiptoe
around this issue this issue is
political Islam is political Islam the
spreading across this country the
disturbances here appeared small and
sporadic but they may only serve to make
matters worse the Muslim Council of
Britain has condemned the attack and
called on the police here to calm
tensions but as many in this
neighbourhood come to terms with the
shock of what happened here many more
will be worried about what may happen
next
flowers in tribute to the dead soldier
were laid at the entrance to Willits
barracks worn note simply read to the
poor young man who lost his life on this
very sad day Nick Martin Sky News will
it